wedding season maybe drawing to a close
but here comes ed sheeran bringing his a
game with the new wedding song of 2015
hey guys I'm so Vichy lazy with ET now
and I was the only reporter on set with
Edie for his new music video thinking
out loud now this is Edie like we've
never seen him before he's in a tux and
on the dance floor
take a look well we had two dances
Brittany and Paul and they came on tour
and taught me five hours every single
day the routine in the video and we just
learn it section by section and ran it
run it run it run it run it I can see
why dancers are in good shape
ed looking handsome as ever ditching his
traditional hoodie for something a
little more formal stepping out of his
normal cameo role and into the spotlight
it's my favorite something I've ever
done
not even on on this album so I wanted to
make sure the video carries it to where
ever it can go I felt like the one thing
that would actually surprise people me
doing this dancing we weren't the only
ones surprised remember when Taylor
Swift posted this tweet quote no one's
ready for what you have up your sleeve I
sent her one of the rehearsal videos I
didn't say anything I just sent her the
video and like because I wanted to see
what the reaction of like one of my
friends would be I was like I think and
there yeah I texted it to a few people
and all the reactions are just like
capital letters and lots of exclamation
marks so yeah what did Taylor say was
she shocked it was just a lot of Punk's
OMGs um with more than 40 hours of
grueling dance rehearsal under his belt
all that practice helped edge shed some
unwanted pounds as did this little diet
swap I've dropped 35 pounds in like
three months just from not drinking beer
yeah I Drive I've been tough to cut out
beer no really I'll just replace it with
vodka but like I got drunk
i junked a little bit now that he's a
lean mean dancing machine we only had
one more question to ask would you ever
do Dancing with stars or Strictly Come
Dancing
no why cuz I've done it now I've got
like that I I don't I've done what I
wanted to achieve and improve I feel
like going back to do it would just be
like no you
milking it you know just going back and
being like hey look what I can still do
you could go right in and win apps
yeah I'll leave that to like
rugby players in England always win and
like yeah like you wouldn't think the
rugby players would win white but they
win every single year over like cricket
players and stuff so I'll leave that to
them